[Music]
randall joins us next he's in waco texas
randall welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are you great how can we help
today
so just kind of uh get started on a
brief little thing um so i come from a
family of uh
addiction and uh
not a very wealthy uh group of people
and uh somehow i was able to break free
from that and i was in law enforcement
for for most of my adult life
and then me and my wife decided that we
were gonna start a trucking company and
we did she quit her job and
you're gonna
everybody's gonna think we're full for
some of the things that we've done but
she quit her job we pulled her
retirement put it all into this business
so anyways
i drive a lot and so i listened to you
guys a lot just
recently
and it wasn't until i started listening
to you guys that i realized i didn't
escape the addiction that my family had
my addiction just spending money
so
that being said
i've rare back really hard i have my
thousand dollar savings
i've got a list of every all my debts
and things
i have our houses paid for
so my most important question the reason
why i'm calling it is because i the
business that we started i had to buy a
new truck and the new truck is like 68
000
and we financed that so the truck
payment is about 1400 a month
that being said the insurance for the
company that i've started is also about
fifteen hundred dollars a month
um
so it just feels really heavy on that
side of things because it makes
my business bills about forty five
hundred dollars a month plus my home
bills about 2200 a month
so um
just trying to figure out
um
the right path to go through should i
try to
ditch this vehicle and get something
else but i just really need something
reliable i don't need to be breaking
down
driving 1500 miles
in a week
well randall i heard you say these words
that always it always gets me a little
riled up when you said i had to
i had to buy the 70 000 truck to start
my business right
you didn't have to you chose to right
yes sir and so the good news is we can
choose to do some other things choose to
make some better decisions and so yes i
would be getting rid of this truck uh
can you find one that's used that you
could pay cash for if you sold it
um
how special is this one
it's not special i mean it's special
because it it does the job but it's not
there's no sentimental value
or anything like that i mean there's
another truck that i have my eye on and
it's about twenty thousand dollars i
love that which is
but it's uh
you know i don't have cash to pay twenty
thousand dollars either that would have
to be another financing situation
uh but it's financing twenty thousand
teams
like so how much could you sell this
truck for today is the car worth the
truck today worth the one that you have
um
well
i haven't looked into that yet um
could you get more than 68 for it
i don't think i can get more than 68 but
i could hopefully get
at or around
that number
okay
is that all of your debts
no i have
everything's broken down so the truck is
68 um
me and my wife together have about 92
thousand dollars in student loans and
there's about 10 thousand dollars in
like credit card payments and such okay
well the way i do this is using the debt
snowball where i list them out from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate and we start attacking
this thing and that means we need to get
this business revenue up or your wife
needs to work a second job i don't know
what that looks like for you guys but
we've got to get this income up because
your payments you can't even breathe
right now
yeah it's pretty tight
how much you guys make a year randall
we haven't completed a full year but um
so
my wife so whenever we started this like
i said my wife she uh we made the
decision that she was gonna stay home
because we i have seven children
but uh
but they they range from 21 years old
and
um all the way down to one years old
so anyways she stays at home with the
baby yeah and um
i'm out i'm on the road a lot
and
how much you make a year how much is it
okay yes yes
so
typically i can bring home probably
a minimum of about ten thousand maybe
fifteen thousand a month
but that's not all profit so a lot of
that goes into fuel and insurance and
other things that are like other vehicle
maintenance needs yeah okay
well i mean the i don't like this option
but you trading down sixty eight
thousand dollar loan for a twenty
thousand dollar loan feels a lot better
to me to clear some of this debt and
give you some breathing room
right that's what i was kind of feeling
um
you know i listened to you guys a lot i
bought the
book and i was listening to it and
probably one day
and
so i'm really trying to follow
everything i just want to i don't want
to
abandon the business because i'm hoping
that it will do better but
it'll do better when you have more
margin in your life first of all even if
the revenue stayed exactly where it is
today but right now you need every
single paycheck coming in or else you're
screwed so yeah and randall and you're
so i i would look at a couple of things
because
what you've just described you guys have
a full life right i mean you got seven
kids
uh you're on the road working um and so
this
business that you guys have that is
awesome
i mean i really i would really take into
consideration okay what am i actually
right because there's a lot of expenses
here you listed out so what is this what
am i actually bringing home for my
family uh what's my passion in this is
it going to our revenues projected to
make more are we going to be growing
this thing right like i don't want and
i'm not saying it's a dead-end business
by any means but i don't want you in
something that you're going to be losing
money
or it's not going to be growing and
you're in this perpetual state of like
gosh you're just gone all the time and
you end up not enjoying it so so the job
situation the the business i really want
you guys to look at and be serious at
even though you make crazy life
decisions you know you you know she came
home you cashed out you cashed out
retirement all of that to start it
um take the emotions out and i really
want you guys to evaluate that business
together and make sure this is the
lifestyle that you guys want as your
family on just the values aspect uh and
then when it comes to the debt
yeah i mean if there's anything now
seven kids that's a full house so but if
there's anything that she can do even
staying at home to bring in some extra
money or even that 21 year old if they
can help support the family if they're
living there
no so she doesn't live there she started
her own family yeah and she graduated
nursing school okay yeah she started
beginning
yeah yeah so this is you guys you and
this this is y'all's decision you know
for for what you guys have done and and
i hear a resolve though in your voice
randall that i think is great i mean i
think you really are at the end of your
rope meaning like you're willing to do
whatever yeah what we've done is not
worked and so
um
it is going to be this idea that it's a
it's a marathon it's not going to be a
sprint and that's the hard thing is we
are so used to seeing results
so quickly we want these things to
resolve so quickly and that's one reason
why we do say the debt snowball because
you at least get these quick wins so
even this ten thousand dollar credit
card debt like if it's multiple credit
cards list them out individually right
like you gotta feel some progress yes i
want you guys to be doing that so um
continue on what you you know sell in
the truck like george said but um keep
chipping away and if there's any way to
raise the income um again and i want you
to abandon a business that you guys
started by any means i don't want to be
i don't want to give you that advice
here on one call
on a four-minute radio call but
but is there is there anything you could
be doing to be making more is there
another a job another industry i don't
know just anything to kind of clean up
this mess for the short term i think um
i mean could you work for someone else
right now and make more on your
take-home pay after all of your expenses
are gone
that could be an option to seek
working with somebody or for somebody
else yeah
i'd get creative man i'd get real
creative at this point and see what are
my options and you know what future
maybe we start that business back up but
right now we've got to clean up a big
mess and you've got a lot of people
relying on this you guys can do it
randall y'all can do this yeah you call
us back we can help in any other way